[Musique]
oui mais venant par la famille s'est
mise à mal depuis cette semaine je peux
pas éviter le sujet des 215 enfants qui
ont été retrouvés dans un charnier
collectif dans un nid qui voudrait dire
un cimetière de pensionnat mais moi
j'appelle ça un charnier puisque pour
retrouver des corps il faut qu'ils aient
été perdues et donc l'anonymat des corps
des personnes des sites aucun endroit où
on peut se recueillir en famille face à
un enfant perdu
vous pouvez imaginer qu'est ce que çà et
là comme emprunt collective sur les
communautés autochtones à travers le
canada
pourquoi je suis ici en colère pourquoi
je suis je peut étonner c'est que c'est
pas des lieux qui sont tout d'un coup en
moto à part une pensée sont des lieux
qui sont connus ce sont des les sites
des pensionnaires sont connus mais
trouvé les corps de ces enfants là c'est
tout un nouveau processus qui vient
peut-être des fois même de sites de
recherche de communautés mais qui vient
pas du canada après que le canada ait
reçu la commission vérité réconciliation
qui avaient entendu parler justement des
charniers qu'elles ont entendu parler
des sites qui se trouve sur les anciens
pensionnaires mais qu' aucune action
collective aucune action liée au
gouvernement a été fait pour retrouver
justement ces six clubs de façon urgente
pour pouvoir guérir une plaie ouverte
sur le canada 16 vous imaginez le
message que cela envoie aux
collectivités autochtones aux
collectivités des survivants des
pensionnats pour pour rien vous cacher
moi je vous dis j'étais responsable des
médias sociaux pendant deux des arrêts
de la commission vérité réconciliation
dont le dernier événement final j'ai
entendu des centaines et des centaines
de témoignages nantes survivants des
pensionnats
j'ai pas seulement entendu comment ils
ont été maltraités comment leur couper
les cheveux
j'ai aussi entendu des histoires où
certains enfants ont dû tenir d'autres
enfants dans leurs bras pendant qu'ils
mourraient parce que les adultes autour
d'eux ne s'active pas si vite pourquoi
réagir ou mal est d'y réagir à un enfant
moore et donc vous imaginez qu'un enfant
qui a un autre enfant est passé d'un nom
du monde des vivants je commande des
membres c'est quelque chose qui prend
votre esprit
quand vous entendez ces témoignages
d'hommes mais c'est pas lisse
témoignages et surtout c'est très
important de savoir c'est que les
pensionnats les meurtres d'enfants les
jeudis bien morte parce que un des
témoignages qui m'a le plus marqué qui
change et à vous dire c'est un squat rue
de wanning c'est un avertissement
il y règne flavell qui était une
ancienne pensionnaire qui expliquait qu'
aucun sévice qu'elle n'a pas vécu mais
qui me qu'il raconte est justement en
public quand elle vu le meurtre d'un
bébé par des religieuses
je vous raconterai pas tout les détails
mais quand elle explique ça brûle
quelque chose en vous et ça vous fait
mais comment est-ce que quelqu'un peut
pas réagir à ça il règne c'est un des
témoignages qui était avant la
commission même avec la commission
encore aujourd'hui on entend des gens
qui disent qu'on a inventé ce de façon
collective parce que des personnes qui
pensent qu'on une conspiration
autochtones à travers le canada pour
dire que les pensionnaires ont pas
existé
j'entends aussi dur que certains
pensionnaires dans certaines provinces
étaient mieux que d'autres
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
mélangent
mais ce qui est certain c'est la
réaction ce qu'ils ont un public les
réactions du gouvernement comment ça
leur prend toujours de 3 minutes et
beaucoup de mobilisations ces médias
sociaux pour réagir face à ce genre
d'annoncés si quelqu'un ment si un
massacre si il ya une découverte d'un
charnier d'êtres humains qui sont
porteuses tonnes il va y avoir une
réaction de deuil collectif
il a depuis quelques jours sur les
médias sociaux on demande à voir
li drapeaux en berne aux demandes
ouah ça quand même un moment de génocide
aux yeux de certains essaient de faire
les communautés qui ont vu des enfants
mourir et comment pouvez vous expliquer
que on voit passer comme une forme de
génocide cas dans certaines écoles à
chaque fois quel virus passé les enfants
mouraient été laissés à eux mêmes
c'est comme s'il y avait eu armée non il
est mort de maladie maladie qui était
contrôlée qui a pas été traité qui a pas
été pris au sérieux par les autorités en
place
vous comprendrez comment nous quand on
vivre ces moments là parce que c'était
moyen âge 9 j'entendais des témoignages
de personnes qui sont vivantes
aujourd'hui cette histoire là c'est mon
histoire parce qu elle connecte à
aujourd'hui à notre vécu les impacts des
pensions les impacts qu'ils ont eue avec
la raf des années 70 un pacte qu'ils ont
avec la sur représentation des
communautés autochtones dans les milieux
carcéraux la sur représentation des
femmes par rapport aux victimes de
criminels sexuels
les bordelais jean semaine des femmes
autochtones assassiné disparu tout ça
est relié à un système et un racisme
systémique où on a pris des enfants on
veut déconnectés de leurs communautés
des gens qui les aimait ont ils ont
jamais réapparu parfois et tout ça vient
se mélanger avec un regard extérieur
déconnecté des fois de la communauté
allochtone par chance plus été moyen ge
avance plus les gens réagissent plus les
gens en réaction viscérale eux aussi par
rapport au décès d'enfants mais vous
comprendrez que c'est très difficile de
voir à quel point on n'est pas encore au
même on n'a pas la même réussite on n'a
pas le droit la même réactivité quand
des choses comme ça par ex est ce qu'on
a trouvé les autres corps parce que c'
est estimé selon la liste des enfants
qui ont été
amasser qui ont environ trois mille
enfants qui ont qui son mandat les
passionnés qui sont jamais revenus et
leur jeudi demande où est formé dans le
franc sont morts supposément en
s'enfuyant des pensions combien
d'enfants sont morts l'exposition au
froid parce qu'ils ont essayé de sauver
des pensionnats et que on l'a on les
menace est justement que si on les
retrouvait finirait au cimetière et je
ne parle même pas combien d'enfants sont
nés des enfants qui étaient dans les
pensions parce que ces histoires là
aussi font partie des pensions alors
imaginez c'est extrêmement profond que
c'est une blessure encore ouverte et que
la commission vérité réconciliation
aurait dû et un choc électrique au
canada pour pouvoir voir l'impact
qu'elle y pense et n'ont eu pour pouvoir
réagir et trouver justement ces sites
redonner aux familles le droit de
pouvoir clore ce chapitre là avec les
restants de leurs enfants
savoir ce qui s'est passé et même des
fois enquêter parce que c'est parce
qu'ils sont morts dans un passionnant
que ce crime ne doit rester impuni est
ce qu'un enfant est mort parce qu'il a
été étranglé son enfant est mort parce
qu'il a été maltraité
est-ce qu'il est mort de faim toutes ces
enquêtes
on n'a pas le droit de nous parce que
c'est un charnier collectif parce que
notre histoire collective
c'est une guérison doivent être
effectivement mais maintenant des
individus demande des réponses comme
n'importe quel citoyen qui perdrait un
membre de sa famille voudrait avoir une
enquête aux criminels pourquoi est ce
que ces meurtres aussi mort de son père
qui était de la même manière donc
comprendre et que ça ça va devenir
quelque chose d'énorme
ça va donner quelque chose qui va être
extrêmement divisée on va nous demander
de passer par dessus et c'est quand même
assez étonnant parce que je t'ai on
parle encore des patriotes sous le pont
jacques-cartier et je comprends pourquoi
on en parle
je comprends pourquoi c'est important
dans l'histoire mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'aime pas les enfants qui sont
morts dans les pensionnats pourquoi
est-ce qu'on emporte les personnes qui
ont été des bourreaux pour ses enfants
c'est lorsque je vois un désintérêt de
notre histoire collective quand ça
touche à des membres des communautés
adapte alors en espérant qu'on peut se
trouver et ils ont le jeu cette
réconciliation ne prennent plus de sens
je vous invite à aller voir justement le
quatrième volume du rapport final de la
commission vérité réconciliation et
genève ou pour viser les toutes les
voies l'homme comprendre et qu'est ce
qui manque dans les grands chefs de
l'histoire canadienne
alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine